hi guys so I'm back in Doncaster today
I'm meeting a builder and I'm going to
be talking him through the plans for the
house and getting his ideas I've
actually just seen a board the next door
and that says rooms Follette so I'm
thinking that we might have an option to
have a plan B for this but I'll share
more about that as we go on add the
builders are actually here and I've also
got a special guest here it doesn't know
much about property so I'm going to be
showing him the ropes today trying to
come on look if all down you are looking
forward to learning you know what though
honestly this house I found this house
and it you don't even know this I found
this house as lukasgruber yeah when I
was doing my financial freedom challenge
I found this house I tried to sell it
and I couldn't sell it as new Kris Ruby
and then I'd already put the offer
forward to this debt agent so that after
the challenge I just thought you don't
forget it man I'll buy it and here we
are
also this house it could be got the
builders here
they're awesome by the way Nick and bang
bang but also this house it could be two
two flats which is what you worked out
which is cool we're gonna get quote now
hopefully or shortly but that I think
there's some there's some there's some
tense of disease among to that so we'll
be looking at the pros and cons and
what's what so we've got round
I lived away also thanks
here we are come on in
Wow but this meeting just about this
house so the reason that I bought this
house is because they bought this house
for ninety six thousand pounds in 2016
and then refurbed it the house next door
Psalm for 120 then put this on the
market I want to women he didn't sell
the points kept dropping I would even
look for so they just get this right
they bought it for ninety six and we
Furr bit and then I bought it in 94 is
that money saver that's why that's but
here's the problem we've met people the
firehouse will refer there to sell it
when they don't have a clue what they do
it now extra because they don't know the
market no clue what I was thinking if
you do this to apartments which is
probably going to be easier because then
do two apartments for 15 one apartment
for 1500 hanumanth gross rent they pay
their own bills and stuff
easy peasy but I know they bring you an
article for yes and I've heard that if
when if you haven't got them completed
by October this year this year you have
to apply for planning permission yeah so
hey I was thinking what we could do
maybe you'll have to work out some stuff
but if we rent out two of these roads
that would mean that we don't run fall
right yes which would mean that we've
met with our plumbing have the desire to
know forever
so that's quite attractive so there's a
couple of little opportunity to go down
there thinking that it's gonna be
apartments obviously upstairs downstairs
downstairs the downstairs bathroom it's
not an completed so it looks like
they're starting to do it but it wasn't
done yeah so downstairs bathroom already
in the kitchen and they don't
there's another bathroom but then one of
the bedrooms the littlest one we look to
change into a kitchen that's what that's
what I was thinking
I think another big thing that I look to
figure out an error but I'd love to see
what you think is where the entrance
would be for upstairs upstairs and then
you can see citizen there's a door just
there and then roasted cumin this is
here and then upstairs personally I'd
seal this off and see if looking up some
stairs on the outside okay
and then you've got all that space extra
space there as well right yeah it makes
it a bit awkward though coming rockets
to losing quite a bit on Theon the box
it's not the widest corridor but that's
what I would just thought naturally I
would have thought either put a door at
the bottom of the stairs yeah and then
the other idea that I thought was having
door pm's then you probably still have
to have the stairs there yeah right
yeah but this is one of the bedrooms
yeah it's a good size the both really
good sized rooms actually and then this
little one here is what we thought would
be the kitchen yeah yeah that bricks
well yeah it is yeah yeah this is
annoying those bricks yeah no it's not
an issue it's not a big job you know
moving a move the wall that brick is a
bit of a [ __ ] you know right upstairs
is a cupboard under there yeah and
that's where the consumer unit is and
yeah in the kitchen that's what I tells
me that I said you've got to consume you
downstairs to separate two separate
flats I will probably either
about their semester you've got an
entrance all coming in you've got your
communal by electrical box at either
side
so they've got both access to that you
could probably make the back door down
to the downstairs flat so you have to
use from front door hind side you know I
mean then they've got like a bit of a
lobby all the way in with their
electrical box are there for access and
then obviously yeah because it separates
and Finance I think you're messing about
just throwing a few ideas about
obviously would you have this is the
bedroom that is the kitchen kitchen and
have that as your living room because
they give them yeah I think so yeah yeah
I want to so it's the downstairs if we
kept that aspect the lobby area yeah
where would they both come into and use
that space then how would we separate
their flat off the dancing yeah that's
what we need to lot it'd be cheaper to
do it that way than upstairs community
and outside and lock in film because the
rents out for my 24 Parliament yeah why
are you wrecking you get on a rebound
this town on each individual flat then
what do you think I'm not I don't know
but I'm not excited no I won't leave yes
well the rents mother Sims and they're
all ours we we know if tomorrow no more
this Vannoy is for rent if we can get
into two apartments or two flats or I
hate to know and you just get a really
good return long-term it's going to go
up
I think Doncaster it's going to be good
but I hope I don't think we immediately
the invest in a lot of money in
Doncaster I know the absolute millions
invest in it so it's good it's got the
rail everything there so it is worth
good Doncaster yeah right what would be
your inclination
would you follow these the clear
problems is easy it's easy for partners
because we are changing fire doors and
stuff meet me personally I don't like it
anymore like we bought ours in Barnsley
up here $67 for 6 better timber and
refurb 2 bathrooms it cash floors
probably about 25 yeah
fitting that we found that's a really
good investment so but for me to go and
buy a niche more anywhere else even if
bit of caution underground no mom these
days hmm
where's I can buy single cash flows near
la ceremonia about three different
assets got three times yeah and six and
yeah if we see painter I guess the good
thing about split into flats is that we
then got two properties yeah which is
cool
yeah definitely I know you're more
inclined I just I just love the fact
that they're bringing in article 4 in
October grandfather right baby but then
I personally chose better to have two
for the price of one but you're one of
your own whether the decision maker on
this one so you know the grandfather
yeah what have you got to prove to that
prove that as it is you've got some
people actually in it I have the
contracts desire that's it like we do to
me this has lieutenant yeah well I'm for
it on a two-week tenancy agreement going
and then they're brought in Olympus it
was department so I mean I got that to
show that this house was used as an HMO
or Malta net prior to October
I'm good forever yeah but it does vary
holiday from counsel - counsel
yeah that's the case in Wolverhampton we
left to check yeah if we're doing
Doncaster but all the homes it's that
simple
hmm well I'm differently and more
aground in chanted they're very similar
yeah oh yeah they only you and I
experience from your own
I'm saying is now how to get the drum
father Roy that's not in there it is so
we could do it tonight
and it is your this is your maker I like
well yeah to come baby so what's a good
program plum they get some green for a
few weeks
mmm Oh interest yeah yeah but let's
definitely get quite a lot of always
there's a backup into you know nothing
about thing and also if your quotes
expensive and with the normal goodness
line all the time we've done that we
have so much money I have yeah well I
bought this house yeah a vintage really
well you know Lucas really limited is
buying this based on the profits from
your problem oh really
so but anyway he came with a quote to do
into two apartments but your Facebook
group yeah animation do so you know and
then with the old possibility of us to
into adventures together and stuff as
well being able obviously benefit you
guys just to get a foot in door do you
guys know but they don't have to check
what they quoted but to be honest like
those ages ago
so yeah is just a bit to do electric
heaters or p.m. as well I think than
checking another gas boiler in and yeah
so they've got a little meter on yes
yeah and it's blue speak comedy seven
years ago it last so it saves on your
gas say it's easy as well yeah cuz that
I was wondering how that would work
I think you're a whole new boiler up
here as well yeah no I'd put electric it
okay
just post more inefficient that is that
yeah and it's only a small yeah it's
also the pollutant is an HMO just for
the sake of dirty grandfather rights
I guess she's other thing is you say
about fired or some stuff there you
could do so if we did do that so to keep
going on play - man you were good to me
this wall yeah because you just hose I
hate remember for three people can be
waiting up from a license would you so
you could literally be so easy I think
personally if it were me this I'm just a
narrative this property for instance
manager for our goal that were going
just because I'm no agent or marquee
around here
meanwhile an agency we're talking about
another project on Twitter in a minute
and he's a hospital for iron tranvía
that energy using about 70 you you're
gonna get out of it yeah anyway first
even numbers work on that then talk what
I would say hmm
would I hate you more room you literally
you just got new friends and fiber like
yes into smoke alarms room throughout
yeah not really much more I would say
we'll work it out yeah and then and then
just see and then see what sighing
thanks but what we've done is well
they've bought one as examples as quotes
what we've just done good job so you can
see how we work and do as pricing so
then everything's itemized see
if your apartment one come in this door
right mmm you're gonna share that door
you know what swap one hopper to get
through there you know you have to block
it's an exciting pasta there's a lot of
scope definitely yeah I'm just wondering
if it would work that as flats or HMO I
don't know
yeah if you could also price it as if
you're putting in fire doors and yes web
systems all that be good are they
it's gonna be cheaper to do it so hope
tonight oh yes what do you think the
quotes gonna be I think I think so as
well
twelve was how much the previous Belden
said when I bought it I don't think
these guys are going to be cheap you see
when I bought it it was twelve they told
me that that was a really bout and
braces quote and it would be the maximum
of twelve whereas these guys I've got a
feeling that twelve is gonna be the
start and part I thinking more like 15 I
think these are expensive but I think
what we won't need to project manager
you could put we could probably get down
fight like a minimum job but but we have
to find our own they'll do a great job
no and I'll also I don't want paying a
bit more because I want to get in with
these guys because their house build us
and because they're doing like big
projects and they don't have some
scratch I want to get in with them and
get a relationship we've done so let's
see what they say that if they say more
than 20 on out they won't say more than
20 I'll be ridiculous twelve I'm going
for twelve we can always negotiate a
little bit with them anyway so at the
moment there's properties that save
rooms Follette which means that HMOs
there's a reasonable amount of supply
for rooms but there's also reasonable
amount of demand the great thing about
October which is just a few months away
is come October they're going to bring
article four into Doncaster which means
that after article four comes in you can
no longer buy a house and then change
its use and rent it out as a multi-layer
or HMO without getting planning
permission
now the reason I'm excited about our
house in Doncaster and I want to do it
as a high tomorrow is because at the
moment there's no article for and if we
rent that out as I hate you know when
article four comes in in October we will
have the grandfather rights which means
that we'll have automatic planning
permission now when you have automatic
planning permission and you have
grandfather rights what happens is of
course the value of the house thing goes
up because you've got plan
permission and what also happens is the
the the the supply for HMO rooms drops
because no one can compete with you no
one can come and buy HMOs in the area
without getting planning permission
which is a pain so that means that
tenants the people that are looking in
the demand they've got less supply which
means that you're not only is your value
of your house color but the rents of
honor so I'm really quite keen on doing
the house as I hide you know because for
that reason but Amanda's pretty adamant
she wants to do it as apartments as flat
why do you want it as flat slice and
dice I know you mean yeah ultimately I'm
gonna let Amanda choose what do you
think what do you think we should do is
comment below and tell me and then
you'll probably say the opposite of what
we ended up doing and I'll kick myself
so the crazy thing is about this house
just just just get this they bought the
house for ninety five thousand pounds in
2016 so just three years ago
they then refurbed it they probably
spent around about twenty thousand
pounds on the house they then tried to
sell it for 120 but couldn't they
dropped it to 110 they dropped it again
to a hundred I came along and bought it
for ninety four thousand pounds which is
cheaper than a port bought it for even
before the refurb so I think I've got a
really good deal you can see the house
right here here's the clerk I'll show
this market information they bought it
for ninety five thousand pounds in 2016
here's the crazy thing they thought
they'd get 120 because if you look at
near sold house prices you can see that
seventy four a as is number 74 sold for
one to one in 2018 said they sold next
door
sold for two thousand three nod for one
hundred and twenty one thousand and it
looks pretty much identical good
condition absolutely one hundred and
twenty one thousand pounds now the
market the areas bottom doubt how do we
know that because in 2007 it sold for
one hundred and forty thousand pounds so
the market right now is absolutely
bottled out this is the floor plan so we
can either rent
as a room this is a room this is a room
this is a room when to Nick a little bit
here to make this room bigger or we can
put that as a kitchen and do that as an
apartment one and that as apartment 2 so
the world's our oyster but long-term
we're definitely going to make some
serious money with this property and I'm
really glad so I've just been into a
hate tumour manager's office and they
didn't want me to film but what they did
tell me is that I could easily get 75
pounds of room for the house which would
be about 1,300 pounds a month with that
said I'm a bit torn now because I don't
know whether we should split it into two
apartments or just rent it out as a HMO
but I've got the Builder now to quote
for both options so once he sends me
those quotes through then I think I'll
make my decision
[Music]